What's the matter? It's almost time.
Hey, today I'm going to be the Ultimate Four Heavenly Kings. Is
everyone late for the party? No, it's not
late, it's
absent.
Everyone rejected your true identity,
Bashbaza-sama and
Grandbaza-sama.  It
seems that you have petitioned the Demon King for your dismissal.
Why is it because of you that the
Demon King's army is in tatters? Mithril has
lost not only the mine, but also the trust of the people and the Demon Master.
How difficult will it be to regain this?
That's why I finally found the secret plan to destroy the hero, and
completed it. It's too late. Just look at this venue and you'll see what I should have
done.
Daniel,
if I had had an aide, I might have done it.
Excuse me.
[Music]
[Applause]  It's
alcohol.
Bring me some alcohol. I can't.
Lately, I've been behind on my payments, and I'd be
foolish to stop the Four Heavenly Kings if I were to be removed from them. Besides, there
was Daniel-sama before I added the Four Heavenly Kings.  So I
was relieved when Dariel-sama was there, as a contract,
but Dariel-
Tariel without Daniel-sama
[Music] You stupid
German
insulted me.
Make everyone regret it.
But he's the one who
insulted me the most.  The person who does this is
banished and
burns down those obscene things without coming to buy anything
[Music]